Film Courage: Telling stories has been fun for you,
working in the entertainment industry
not so fun? I think that was a quote from
you somewhere. Joe Wilson, Filmmaker/Writer/Artist: Yeah I think that's some
points when you're banging your head
against the wall in your try and that
and that is I mean that is a career that
is what you do if you want to be
successful you keep writing and you keep
banging your head against that wall
until something goes the thing that
crossed my mind because I had some
friends die young was that I was
relatively young and was I going to die
typing and not making anything like all
I want like I made I wrote to have three
shorts maybe cuz they just wanted to
have something me like just well I'm
typing I just want to see this happened
and then when I saw it happen like I
literally could not go to the screening
because I was so angry at how bad
everything was and and so I I think at
some point it was just like literally
like freak this why am I doing this what
this has been years and I have gone
through managers and ups and downs and
projects that were gonna be huge and and
not you know little tiny things happen
but not enough for a career not enough
to you know you so all you're doing is
stringing together a bunch of temp jobs
that is what that the entertainment
industry is it is a bunch of temp jobs
yeah maybe you get lucky enough to be on
a show that lasts four years but most of
times these are temp jobs you're working
one day maybe a week maybe a few months
and then there's no work and sometimes
you have a great gig and you make a ton
of money and then nothing happens ever
again and that is a reality that happens
no one wants to talk about it because no
one wants to hear you know there's this
really good possibility you're gonna
spend all your time and all your life
and all this time nothing's going to
happen and
and that's it and you're gonna look back
and you're gonna think hey that was a
lot of money that was a lot of time Wow
so that was my life huh interesting
hmm maybe uh maybe I want to change
things up a little bit and the most fun
I had was when I said freak it the most
fun I had that's when things started
going together that's when things
started just it seemed effortless when I
stopped looking for people to say yes to
a script when I was just like I'm making
this do you want to help changes
everything and then when you make
something and it doesn't tank and then
you can use that to make something else
and then that doesn't tank and then use
that and you can then you're slowly
building these little tiny increments
until you have a couple hours online of
a bunch of stuff you've made and then it
exists and people see it and it doesn't
disappear and what's amazing and the
thing that you do not know when you make
anything online is stuff that I made in
oh six I got a comment on last week oh
wow so that's the thing that nobody
tells you like this YouTube's not going
anywhere it's not going in there and as
far as I know they're not cleaning out
the old stuff so if you have your short
up there yeah maybe it doesn't have 20
billion views maybe it didn't go viral
maybe whatever maybe just maybe it
doesn't tank maybe it will entertain
amuse whatever someone why did you start
to do this to begin with and I started
to do this because I was like I love
when I'm sitting down and something
happens on a screen or on a stage and I
and it makes me feel different I want to
be able to create that how do I do that
spend freaking decades typing and
stand-up and acting and like going to
school through photography really came
in handy when I was a director because
all of a sudden all of a sudden that the
SLR was a video camera and I'm like yeah
I know that all these numbers about them
memorized forever like I can I can tell
everybody would have stuff to go to
because I knew it when I was 11
like so it made all this stuff really
easy you know I knew focal lengths and
all that stuff none of it I knew the
shape of 35-millimeter because I had
been taking pictures and trying to fit
the world in that so I had I was one up
on everybody I didn't need a director of
photography because they've taken so
many great pictures because I've spent
years learning how to do it so now I'm
just making one step move that's why I
never went tripod because I'm like I
want to be able to get whatever I want
whenever I want it I do not want to try
around it's too slow it's too slow I
want three cameras two operators here
I'm operating boom cover cover cover
cover cover next
did your parents like their jobs you
know yeah my father I think I did for
just some degree and I think my mother
tolerated it I guess
they both came from poor backgrounds and
my father was a construction working
construction as a plumber Union down
Ossining area and my mother worked on an
assembly line for IBM and then worked
her way up to be a CAD operator and then
both of them get messed over be forced
everybody in a retirement and then hired
people back his attempts to to train the
replacements oh and then the union was
learning to run out of money and start
cutting off you know benefits and stuff
so I think when I saw them get messed over I
was just like I'm not gonna work my tail
off so so I can be a cog in somebody
else's machine just that is the one
great thing that came from my parents
going like they did all the great things
American dream high school educated
family we all went to college house they
did everything right
still got messed over
so I didn't want to do that so do you
think that's what kind of like lit a
fire under you to say okay I'm gonna go
from wherever to Boston do some stuff
okay then I'm gonna take this chance
this person communicated with me said
come to LA and so you knew that's not
the life for Joe Wilson I'm not gonna be
doing that I'm not gonna work for some
company and then I mean politely or not
so politely push down the door yeah
that was the goal I did end up working
for a company for 11 years that I owned
a little tiny piece of that was started
by writers and actors that's still in
business so it's not like I'm against
you know I'm not like damn the
corporation's I just know what happens
to companies when they get big when
companies get big they care less about
people they you know when Ford had the
Pinto in the seventies and when people
hit it and it blew up for it said well
we can either recall and pay for that or
we can just pay for all the lawsuits and
they chose the lawsuits and they're
still in business amazing one of their
cars so do you ever go back and say well
I know I'm typing at this one desk and
here I'm wearing this one metaphorical
hat as this job and then I'm turning
around and I'm typing at this other desk
as a quote creative storyteller even if
I don't make a million dollars right
away or in the next 20 years I sort of
do this or ever I still want to do this
because this is who I am and I can't
stop telling stories and I don't want to
have a job that I hate that I have to go
to and I have to smile at people and
make it seem like I want to be there and
I don't really want to be there and my
boss is an idiot and I'm having meetings
about meetings but I didn't do this
screenwriting so I've given up you think
there's a I don't know say that well I
guess my question with all that
gibbering jabbering that I'm doing is
like even if there isn't Hollywood
putting a stand
even though
you loved vampire mob and it has views
and people gave you feedback yeah sure
if you want to do a second version of
something right but no because Hollywood
said they didn't want me so I'm not
touching that again is that where you're
at I guess I got there years ago to not
acknowledge the entertainment industry
to kind of like if I if I could make
something without it then and the end
result it was it was sort of like I
needed to get to the audience and the
thing that was between me and the
audience was all the companies that make
the stuff to show to the audience so if I
could find some way to get around them
and get to the audience which social
media allowed you know and I've I've had
people and continued to have people find
stuff and and like stuff and you know
you make somebody laugh when they're
having a bad day or a bad life or a bad
you know time and I know my wife was
diagnosed with cancer a few years ago
and I know how much comedy really can
help like I have seen it firsthand so
there's a value in in making stories you
know whether it's drama or comedy or
whatever the genre but I think you know
now because there's I think the number
of guest star performances to be
considered for Emmys was two thousand
eight hundred and something performances
so if you have that many potential
nominees for for guest when you have
thousands of performances and they have
thousand there are more shows then
anyone can get to in their lifetime if
they wanted to do it full time and just
watch television they couldn't get to it
all so now I'm making more stuff for
them to watch
why why am I going to make something
that I have to be in the same boat that
Netflix and everyone else is like how do
you get all these how do you get that
much attention like everyone is so
Twitter Facebook Instagram snapchat what
I got to watch something what oh there's
something wrong yeah music how do you
get their attention they I think if
you're going to be indie that you have
to spend years again know your audience
and talking to and I and I have changed
my term a little bit in terms of
audience because now I I see the people
I know online as neighbors because I
talk to them all the time
you don't talk to audience all the time
audience is this thing that's over there
and you're over here and and I think a
lot of people like that a lot of people
like hey I'm over here you're over there
I act you stay over there I'm a director
you stay over there when you talk to
people every day because you're not
making everything all the time like you
I don't care how good of a producer or
you're not putting out movies all the
time as an indie person so there's going
to be all this time that you're not
going to have something new and if
you're spending all your time on social
media talking about your freaking project
Holy moley, really? More tell us more
you typed another page yay come on that
is not I I know it interests you and I
know it's a great thing for you but
you're just typing you know you finished
a screenplay okay I'll give you that but
I I didn't know that thousand words shut
up tell me about the thousand words have
you've done fifty thousand and then a
hundred thousand and then three hundred
thousand then maybe you talk about the
words a little bit but just because you
typed all November to get to get a novel
out doesn't mean you made anything good
it just means you typed every day
tantrum was about that's okay I enjoyed
it oh good I'm glad the I think the a
story can have a value without the
entertainment industry and the
entertainment industry doesn't value
stories they value profit the Marvel
Universe is a very big complicated story
but that is something that has an
audience that was built in four decades
and you only mark it at a level that is
saturation when you're playing with
literally billions of dollars but all
that's for other people that's not for
me and that's not for most people that
is that's the giant machine that is you
will be a cog in that machine unless
you're on screen you will be because
it's just too big and even if you are on
screen you're still really disposable
because that is Disney has bought the
world and that is really valuable
property right now just like in SAY
ANYTHING movie and forgive me I'm thinking of
John Cusack's character but he's
basically I don't want to you know
produce you know buy anything that you
know I was talking her dad at dinner
right right right
aren't we all sort of owned by somebody
though I don't care if we work for
Marvel and oh yeah we're on the red
carpet and and they want your picture or
sure you're working for a company yeah
you have to work for something yeah we
selling business to sell stuff to make
money that way so all of my customers
are technically my boss sure
I don't think nor do I expect what I
make to generate enough income for me to
live on what I do online it's more it's
just like anything else it's a gig it's
just a little gig you do something maybe
making a little bit of money and then
get to put another one together and
another one together and I was enrolled
when my wife had cancer that roll the
wind and the sails stopped and
storytelling was not important anymore
and was not a priority
and was not anything that I thought
about for a long time because I had
other stuff that was more important and
I think I think the other thing about
this is that sometimes and I've seen
people do it to their demise literally
sometimes people make the entertainment
industry and success and and more
important than anything else including
other people and at some point you're
going to end up being an empty shell of
a human being at the other end of it and
you will maybe you won't regret it but
man you're gonna be better as hell
because it's just when when when the the
socializing in Los Angeles is based on
perceived success whether it's current
recent or about to happen and people
I've had the and it's the classic thing
you're out the party and someone's
talking to you but they're like and that
person is way more important I really
need to go talk to that person but yeah
yeah I'll be right with you and then
they go talk to that person or or the
classic hey you're gonna come to my show
now when is that no it's a road if I
show up late oh no you know I think I
have this thing you know I'll try to be
there okay that's an LA that's an LA
definitely so you're definitely gonna be
there then definitely probably trying to
maybe be there yeah made me but all but
I'll try thank you they're not showing
up I remember when I was doing stand-up
comedy everybody was doing one-man shows
or one per solo shows so everybody was
just trading off everybody's just going
to each other shows because we needed an
audience and because there's just so
many comedians and there was so little
audience in Los Angeles what's gotten
that way with crowdfunding it's like you
want to donate to people's campaigns but
after a while we just had another guest
that reminded me of that and that's a
great point that you want to be able to
give to these
campaigns over and over again but you've
already given to so many and you're kind
of like tapped out and I think that's
that's part of the problem but going
back to storytelling do you plan on
giving up storytelling no no no no no I
when I was doing Vampire Mob [Joe Wilson's web series] I one of
the cast members Marshall Wallace died
and I had written a whole season three
and the idea of trying to make it
without her seems weird like I easily
could have written around it I easily
could have cast someone else and it was
just kind of like this isn't I don't
know it just didn't feel right so I went
graphic novel I went comic book and I
don't know anything about comic books I
didn't grow up reading comic books I'm
not a comic book guy so then I had to
learn about comic books learn how to
write comic books and man I wish I had
done that like before I ever took a
screenwriting class because for you to
have so I'm adapting a screenplay into a
comic book
so I have it all written but it can't
just get dropped it isn't like I'm just
taking the script and then oh look it's
a storyboard with words it's like you
have to go through and like what are the
five panels that you're going to put on
this page they're gonna tell the story
and you're gonna have to leave most of
it out because you can't have this giant
long thing because you want to watch
your character walk through the alley
for an hour you've gotta go so it
changes how you see story achieve now
all sudden you think oh I want this
panel on this page to end so when they
turn the page and they see that top
panel the surprise will be there you're
literally writing like that there's no
plot points it's page points and the
challenges with making graphic novel I
just put an issue to to the printer so
the second issue will be coming out soon
ish the challenge is working with
artists getting artists
I can't draw the frustration to be
honest
putting the two books together has
resulted me writing a book so I am forty
five thousand words into something
called Bob Barry's things it was an idea
I had a couple years ago and I just
needed something somewhere to go like I
when I'm writing um I disappear
completely as the way I look at it I'm
daydreaming on a page writing is
orchestrated daydreaming I'm just
daydreaming
it's not hard to daydream so it's really
easy and I like it and now I spent it
takes a long time to write a book
and I expect like fifty people to read
it and that's my expectation and maybe
my expectation will be beat but I'm
asking somebody not only take time out
of their day but a lot of time to read a
book so I don't have any expectation I
don't know what people will I didn't
write this from a marketing point a John
Rowe point anything like that it was
just an idea and I ran with it
and and the weirdest thing is I I listen
to the book I have the program read it
back to me so it's sort of like an audio
book being read by a robot and I listen
to what I wrote and then I hear what's
wrong with it and then I can go back and
change it that I never would see if I
was just just reading and even if I was
reading it loud I wouldn't catch it like
that
you